s
les temps.
- La série hockey Canada-URSS.
- Qui va remporter la série
Canada-Russie?
- Bien, ça ne fait pas
l'ombre d'un doute pour moi :
c'est le Canada.
- Les joueurs du Canada,
ce sont des professionnels, puis
les joueurs de la Russie, c'est
des amateurs, ça fait que...
- La Série du siècle s'amorce
au Forum de Montréal devant
le premier ministre Trudeau,
Pierre Elliott Trudeau.
Phil Esposito donne les devants
au Canada dès la 30e seconde.
Après un deuxième but
des représentants de l'unifolié
à la septième minute,
les partisans se sont dit
que c'était dans la poche,
que le Canada était trop fort.
Mais les Soviétiques démontrent
leur supthlétique et
technique contre des Canadiens
vite essouflés, loin d'être
prêts à jouer au rythme infernal
de la grosse machine rouge.
SERGE SAVARD, ancien défenseur-t
une défaite ce soir, je pense
que les gars vont être un peu
blessés dans leur orgueil
et vont peut-être prendre
l'entraînement plus au sérieux
qu'ils ne l'ont pris
jusqu'à date.
- (commentateur): Les Russes
exercent un contrôle de
la rondelle et jouent sans
manifester la moindre fatigue.
- Le doute est installé,
tant chez les joueurs que
chez les partisans, à la suite
de la raclée subieéal.
Une courte victoire suivra
à Toronto, mais après un match
nul à Winnipeg, les joueurs
canadiens se font huer lors
d'une défaite à Vancouver...
- Et c'est le but!
- ... Ce qui soulève l'ire de
Phil Esposito, une des grandes
étoiles canadiennes.
Après une seule victoire
en quatre matchs, l'équipe
canadienne prend lne prend lne n
de l'Europe, où elle affronte
d'abord la Suède pour poursuivre
sa remise en forme et s'adapter
aux patinoires du hockey
international, plus grandes que.
- Phil Esposito!
- Lors du premier match
à Moscou, Phil Est une
chute lors de la présentation
des joueurs et salue élégamment
la foule, qui en fera
immédiatement un de ses favoris.
Mais le Canada aussi trébuche,
laisse filer une avance de
trois buts et s'incline 5-4.
- Et compte!
- Les Canadiens n'ont plus
le choix : ils doivent gagner
les trois matchs suivants pour
sauver leur honneur et gagne
la série.
Le désespoir s'exprimera
par de l'intimidation et du jeu
violent, notamment un coup
de bâton de Bobby Clarke qui
fracasse la chevilleur
joueur soviétique, Valeri
Kharlamov.- Un lancer d'Esposit.
- La tension sera à son comble
lors des trois derniers matchs,
qui seront tous gagnés par
le Canada par un seul but
à chaque fois; et les trois buts
de la victoire auront été
marqués par le même homme :
Paul Henderson.
- Et devant le but...
Et le but de Henderson avec
un quart de seconde encore!
- Conspués à leur départ
du Canada, les hockeyeurs seront
accueill
retour après une victoire encore
célébrée 50 ans plus tard.
- S'élever aussi haut
émotivement, c'est presque
impossible. C'est presque
impossible. C'est un moment
qu'on n'oubliera jamais.
- Jean St-Onge,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.